pardis do not smell bad they really
don't or I wouldn't spend so much time
doing this my name is Kate Horowitz and
I run the Oregon House where a
sex-positive community and our mission
is to normalize a non-monogamy and
sexual exploration my name is Ellis and
I am the chief operating officer of the
Oregon House and I'm the chief executive
officer of the mango dome a space for
sex positivity in sex classes and sex
parties and I'm the executive director
of the orgy dome at Burning Man
I've been with my husband now for eight
years and it's been something that we've
been talking about together for a really
long time many of the spaces I was
finding parties for people to come and
sex certainly explore non-monogamy run
by men and I thought that I needed to
change I started going to play parties
for the first time when I was about 22
ended up working with Ben and Kate
helping them organize the the organized
parties and after that I started the
mango dome and started throwing parties
there once you kind of build that
reputation it snowballs from there we do
ask everybody to know their STD status
before they go to any play party if you
do have a positive status that's okay
like we still welcome you we're not
gonna ask anybody for any paperwork I
don't think it's an ethical choice to
keep somebody out of any event just
because they have some disease I don't
want to perversely incentivize anybody
to lie about that fact either you must
disclose that information to any
potential partners one of the things you
have to do to define these spaces is be
open with people about what you're
looking for reddit has been a good
resource for people because there are
some subreddits there about non-monogamy
open relationship there's a few
different feeder events that we have
like Holi happy hour it's a good place
to get to know other people that are
already in the community we asked
everyone to apply and list a current
member as a reference
they're extremely inclusive events from
trans men and trans women to LGBT people
I am very very openly bisexual queer
community is there in force we do not
ask people to submit photos when they
sign up I've been to those parties where
everyone is screened
you have to submit a you know picture
and end up in a room full of people that
think they're really hot and are
actually really boring no means no used
to be a popular slogan and now it's been
replaced by yes means yes but what does
that mean does it mean you have to say
yes every five minutes so what we
decided to do is actually come up with
the rules that we felt would keep people
the safest in our space naked in a room
full of strangers even just a touch on
the shoulder can feel more forward than
it was intended producing a culture
based around enthusiastic consent is one
of our very primary goals we make every
single person who applies get on an
orientation call with us that consent
looks like a guess or I know you don't
owe this person an explanation for why
you're gonna say no all you have to say
is no thank you I encourage people to
even practice saying no here just
because I asked that I could touch your
shoulder does not mean that I can touch
your butt you need to ask for consent
for every step in that process consent
can be revoked at any time this isn't
like an FYI for men this is everybody it
is explicitly stated during the party
that if you have any questions concerns
or want to report something that feels
uncomfortable you are more than welcome
to come up to anybody that has one of
the glowing wristbands on that we wear
during the party to identify people that
you can come up and approach this is one
of the places where we can kind of
gently course-correct when people have
bad consent practices or bad habits if
we feel like somebody is purposefully
breaking the rules they are no longer
welcome at our of us I'm a girl and I
run the event so I think that there are
a lot of women who hopefully see me and
feel safer this party is for everybody
but it is specifically a safe place for
young women like me to come and explore
these you know fantasies and questions
that you have about yourself will never
say come see all these sexy women or
like grow so you never say that the
stereotype is that oh you're gonna host
a sex party and it's just gonna be a ton
of single horny dudes that show up we've
often had parties that are female
dominated women are just as horny as men
and if you provide a safe environment
for them to feel like they won't be
slut-shamed and they can express their
sexuality freely it turns out that
there's a lot of men that are
intimidated by that and a lot of women
let her interested in being in that
environment
[Music]
at the party we have delicious delicious
cheese platters condoms Lou and puppy
pads and wet wipes clean sheets and
fluffy pillows tampons and pads saucy
sticks and mouthwash mouthwash cups and
q-tips the highest budget that we ever
had was about five grand we do not make
any money off of it on average it's
about a hundred and ten 120 focus on the
number of people per square foot in the
orgy basically you need about 12 square
feet - - and so we'll measure like the
amount of space that we have so your
studio has 60 60 then when we start
giving out tickets like when we've sold
less to get we're like okay we haven't
worked together the cleanup crew is a
rave crew it's usually headed by Ellis
this guy
well actually literally we'll post on
Craigslist I need a team of people to
clean up after a sex party there's a lot
of volunteers and we give them a free
ticket or something one guy sent me a
response saying in my home country I
used to clean up crime scenes you'll
never know that anything ever happened
it's just like cleaning up after a
regular party there's just as many dirty
cops and fallen soldiers it's just much
more relaxed than they expected it's
kind of democratizing to see that other
people's bodies have flaws - I think one
of the biggest misconceptions is it's a
free-for-all anything goes you wouldn't
be able to say no to anything if you
were there it's a bunch of people most
of whom are friends with each other that
liking their friends
there's absolutely our goal and one of
my core missions in life to D stigmatize
sex and sexuality we're in the midst of
seeing a sexual revolution and it is our
goal to try to foster that movement and
try to be an incubator for us we've put
a lot of effort into making Oregon House
and our events something that we're
really proud to talk openly about I'm
not like ashamed to invite anybody to
this I don't have like a separate you
know alter-ego that I use to host these
or anything I'm just me and that's how I
want the people who come to our parties
to be able to feel about this part of
their lives awesome you could totally
have a 60 person order to get her can I
[Music]